bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors on va déjà parlé de
la première vague
on a beaucoup parlé d'un continent
relativement épargnée jusque-là pour
quelles raisons ben écoute et merci déjà
de m'inviter
je crois que comme vous l'avez dit en
introduction la population africaine est
relativement jeune
quand on regarde la pyramide des âges
elle est quasiment opposée à celle qu'on
vend en occident je crois que c'est
l'une des raisons est peut-être que la
seconde raison là vraiment c'est des
supputations parce qu'on a senti les
terres clair mais l'une des raisons non
négligeable aussi serait probablement
que du fait de multiples réflexions du
banditisme d'autres maladies
infectieuses qui y sévissent en afrique
à longueur d'année peut-être que je dis
bien peut-être que le système
immunitaire ici chez certaines personnes
et est bien qu lui est bien plus
performant et donc probablement
limiterait le nombre de cas de cas très
très sévère mais peut-être aussi qu'il
ya un facteur environnemental mais tout
cela ne devrait être étudiée qu'après
parce que comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
en afrique qui n'est pas toujours aussi
simple de faire des études digne de ce
nom d'un bep en tout cas moi je
résumerais 110 entre la jeunesse de la
population probablement le fait que le
système immunitaire étant très très
sollicités toute l'année du fait des
pathologies multiples infectieuses
peut-être que les gens répondent un
petit peu mieux à cette pandémie alors
des résultats bons pour le continent
cette année 2020 mais pour comptabiliser
les cas positifs il faut les tester dans
certains pays africains
est ce qu'il y avait une véritable
capacité de dépistage n'ont pas tous
quand vous parlez d'afrique sur
l'afrique 6 tonnes les normes continent
je crois que les situations sont très
diverses d'un endroit à l'autre je pense
que l'afrique du nord
c'est pas tout à fait la même situation
qu'en afrique subsaharienne l'afrique du
sud aussi
je crois que ces deux endroits où les
statistiques sont un petit peu plus
fiable que dans le reste de l'afrique
parce que comme vous venez de le dire il
n'est pas toujours aisé d'avoir l'était
pour pouvoir faire la pcr qui chez vous
en occident et le moyens de diagnostic
le plus fiable
ici on fait beaucoup beaucoup appel aux
tests de diagnostic rapide
justement parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
pcr donc évidemment c'est vrai que le
nombre de cas relativement faible peut
aussi être expliquée par le nombre de
tests fiables réaliser alors aujourd'hui
on a une augmentation du taux de
létalité on a une deuxième vague
manifestement plus meurtrière que la
précédente de 25 % de mortalité sur le
continent contre 2,2 de moyenne mondiale
comment l'expliquer j'ai pas j'ai pas du
pape personnellement d'explication
vraiment rationnelles à sam et des mois
dans la petite porte que chez dans notre
centre et même dans l'autre dans la
ville de douala fois au cameroun n'y a
pas assez de cette augmentation je pense
que le nombre de décès a tué clé
probablement sans que je ne puisse vous
donner des chiffres et ça est très
certainement au cameroun plus bas que ce
qu'on a connu au mois de mars avril mai
donc peut-être que c'est une peut-être
qu'à d'autres explications dans dans
d'autres pays d'afrique mais ans au
cameroun en tout cas je ne pense pas que
la mortalité augmente et je crois
qu'elle est même un petit peu plus
faible que ce qu'on a connu au mois de
mars avril 2020 d'ailleurs vous êtes
directeur du centre de maladies
respiratoires à douala aujourd'hui
quelle est la situation sanitaire au
cameroun mais la situation sanitaire
globale n'est pas très bonne en ce qui
concerne le coc vide en particulier
comme vous l'avez dit on avait remarqué
qu'à partir du mois de septembre les cas
étaient quasiment inexistants mais café
à la faveur des fêtes de fin d'année du
multi que voyage de gens qui venaient
voir leurs parents au pays et ainsi de
suite on a on a connu une remontée
vraiment importante autour des fêtes à
dire qu'à partir du 2 mi décembre
bono d'un gang en tout cas merci à vous
d'être d'avoir été avec moi je rappelle
que vous êtes directeur du centre
maladies respiratoires de douala au
cameroun